this new highway running through nairobi
is the most expensive road per kilometer
ever built in kenya its initial cost of
nearly 600 million dollars rose by about
a third with little explanation given by
the government
anti-corruption activists say it's just
the latest overpriced infrastructure
project enriching corrupt politicians
most road users are still stuck in
traffic on the old road unable to afford
the tolls and motorbike taxi drivers
like duncan aquilo aren't allowed to use
it the government has been corrupt those
who are working in government are very
much corrupt
so i think corruption is a problem
kenyan did due to vote in general
elections on tuesday the anti-graft
commission recommended 241 candidates be
disqualified from running because of
corruption but almost all of them have
been allowed to run i mean there's been
always questions about where he got his
wealth corruption scandals have been the
subject of many of patrick gathara's
political cartoons he's often drawn both
of the main contenders for president
former prime minister ryla rodinga and
deputy president william ruto they've
all been
kinda implicated and have been part of
the system that has been uh looting from
kenyans
for a long time it's one of the reasons
why
sort of at a crawling pace you know when
it could be running
you know um a lot of our resources are
actually not spent on ourselves they're
spent on uh
on the corrupt on politicians when ryla
redinger was prime minister some of his
family members were implicated in a
scandal of stolen maze subsidies he's
been telling his supporters that he's
the one who can fight corruption both of
the main candidates accuse the other of
corruption
and both of them deny it
william ruto oversaw those made
subsidies as agriculture minister he's
also promising to fight corruption
he's been deputy president for the last
nine years during which activists say
corruption has ballooned as has
borrowing to fund it
china lent the money to build the new
highway it's one of several costly
infrastructure projects built by the
government of ruto and outgoing
president uhuru kenyatta when the
present administration was was elected
for every 100 of
of tax collection
debt servicing was 20. today it's close
to 56.
and now that can continue forever
because then it means that there's
there's insufficient money to actually
pay for other public services or more
borrowing is going to take place
meanwhile candidates are promising to
tackle the soaring cost of living but
things may get worse before they get
better
the imf wants kenya to end food and fuel
subsidies to prevent a debt crisis
officials in the incoming government
will expect their share of patronage
kenya faces a massive economic challenge
whatever the next leader does kenyans
will likely pay the price
malcolm webb al jazeera nairobi kenya
all right for more on this let's bring
in jackie nawanki she is a lawyer and
analyst based in nairobi good to have
you with us first of all does it look
like we're witnessing something of a
turning point in this election with
voters focusing more
on economics on corruption concerns
rather than the usual sort of ethnic and
personality politics
um first of all thank you for having me
yes i'd say that because we are now more
the concern that kenyans have is about
how much would it cost how little affect
our daily lives do we get what how much
will our food cost our children going to
school so yes very much we've shifted
we're looking at
bigger issues now and i'm very happy
about it
what is causing that shift is this the
the fallout from the war in ukraine and
covid crises
covered kobe definitely led to a massive
shift because even in kenya it affected
especially the campaign period we had a
number a number of uh
campaigns cancelled during this uh
during the kobe period because of safety
concerns and i think it's it's it's
changed the way in which our politicians
could approach people because it's just
more recently towards the end of the
election year in period we've begun to
see crowds but before that they couldn't
use that approach and
and the cost of living has risen sharp
so kenyans are more concerned with how
is my pocket being hit and uh with the
fuel subsidy being taken away
how is that
building up the frustrations people have
with corruption
it it definitely is because you're being
hit more everything has gone up in fact
uh recently i saw a statistic where the
value of 1000 kenya shieldings compared
to
what it was in 2013 is
542 shelling
so
right now going to the supermarket
people are spending double what they
were spending
buying power everything has become
really expensive so kenyans right now i
feel like people are leaving more hand
to mouth than they ever have before
so that changes how we look
given the accusations that have been
made to the candidates concerning
corruption do any of them
have that strong sort of mandate or
record in front of the people to to
really say hey i'm the champion of
corruption
i think at this point um the
overwhelming feeling amongst kenyans you
know there are two camps the kenyans
because none of them really represents
what corruption is corruption in kenya
is institutional it's been there for
years
um both of them have actually served in
government before we um therefore
there's a general sentiment that they
haven't been able to address this during
their time as
uh people leaders and people in
positions of power they could influence
policies that could help us at the same
time these and those and that means much
words happen
and on the other side because this year
these are sorry there's a lot of water
happening this time but on the other
side there are the kenyans who are
hopeful that knowing where we've gotten
that we are up against the war and what
our debt levels have become we're hoping
that whoever comes in comes with uh
hopefully a canoe a new approach of
darshan but and also the new imf
whatever imf is putting as the new
restriction rules that they give in
kenya kenyans are hoping that that will
also force leadership to handle things a
bit differently
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much for your thoughts and analysis
thank you